yeah new five-minute game against rue du
spiral I hope this guy's not doing
something bad to me with some voodoo
stuff on the chest Bartlett's and check
this first as a Solian and care what
line maybe go for this Kalashnikov if he
plays d4 of course many players nowadays
play one of those can't those kind of
lies hmm c3 yeah well it's not like I
never saw this move but then I'm
thinking what I could could play against
that okay let's play 65 at least I know
this kind of structures a bit we might
um transpose into a French after d4 d5
yet d 45 what can play you five wooden
ya hear d 5 with the advanced french
yeah or take on d5 III m the nagano
black can play ac4 were some a closed
position or f6 with a sharp position
let's play a 6 trying to get some
sharper play going ok I get some some
nice development so take on d4 now or
play Bishop t6 our let's go but should
be six first and see if you maybe takes
on c5 at some point
interesting rookie one young okay
playing on the e fala some not exactly a
surprise but then it this move sometimes
we concern we can serve the f the f two
were square so um ok I want them to get
out of possible Bishop h7 stuff after
taking queen bee six for example that I
did I actually threatened deform exactly
take and now I'm i was thinking about
them possible technical operations here
on f 2 h 2 and so on 94 for example is
also a move that i wanted to prepare
come on let's do this I mean I've got
all my pieces out the rukon the effort
is simply the only piece not playing is
the AAA brook and why just got bishop on
see one night on on b1 and it's not
clear what all this is doing yeah well
now I can take on h 2 a.m. this is this
is at least I mean I can also take d for
the question is what what is better it's
probably a both just winning okay take
here okay take here if it takes Bishop
takes King takes Queen edge for checking
g1 Queen text f to check king h2 Queen
h4 check kingi 124 and at the end i win
the rook or the bishop long line but
it's completely forcing all checks and
captures and yeah
he doesn't really am have a move can
okay can play some some ignore move
right in town then I just got this pawn
also I could take on d4 because he
cannot take on could not retake on
before because of Bishop h2 with made
our winning the Queen so this was the
alternative maybe he needs to play some
bit should be two or something some move
like that here and now the question is
do I have something better than night
back to G form I mean it's a porn that I
won but it's not them um not much more
yeah let's just let's just drop back
here you cannot move the f3 naturally I
can capture and catch f2 and term okay
tween f6 looks good you more pressure on
the FL yeah probably wants to go look to
UM to h1
okay well aged six is a good
prophylactic move damn he cannot move
the knight on f3 and as long as this is
not possible I don't have anything to
worry about what I'd like to do is play
a 65 of course but this um can easily
lead to to some kind of self pin so i
don't want that and I don't know what to
be five also this was wasn't move that
he could have played to dislodge the
night which has a fine physician on that
c6 this is why I played a six just them
try to keep it simple so should I play
you five now this is the question maybe
prepare with this he cannot move the
night now anyway and if he goes look
somewhere yeah I was more thinking about
Luke age form it now he five maybe oh he
resigned did you blunder something and I
didn't see it not sure so yeah well yeah
play five this is so okay the computer
actually some minus five this is some
somewhat more than I expected yeah I was
intending e5 and something like this
which it takes to immediately get rid of
pins and then we are thinking yeah the
problem is now he's completely tied up
Bishop g4 and everything's coming on the
central files yeah this was an opening
opening disaster here Nyjah for its now
tricky already really because of 94
night f 2 nite h2s are quite
quite much and this is why I needed to
play King age 88 to prepare all this I
wouldn't play King edge 80s garb Bishop
h7s response King takes 95 Quincy form
and this is working AJ deserve a good
move yeah thanks for watching no it's a
taking game